dans les régions plus loin des grands
centres souvent ce qui gardent les
villages en vie ce sont les fermes mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire opérer la
dernière ferme d'un village dans un coin
de la Gaspésie ça signifie se retrousser
les manches et miser sur l'avenir
pour la route 132 en quittant la vallée
de la matapedia les rivières
restentigouches et matapedia seront
contre de l'autre côté vers le
Nouveau-Brunswick la route monte vers
une pointe sud les plateaux et ces
villages celui tout au bout à l'ouest
est l'ascension de Patapédia on est
rendu ici vraiment c'est le dernier
village de canton vraiment en région
forestière
et au bout de la terre de Marc couture
apparaissent les forêts du
Nouveau-Brunswick
couture et sa famille possède une grande
bergerie un troupeau sélectionné de 1000
brebis dans des bâtiments récents
[Musique]
et une relève bien en place
une belle fille
[Applaudissements]
on est producteurs
à réaliser aussi et qu'on produit 800
heures de céréales on fait aussi du
déneigement l'hiver je suis avec mes
deux garçons genre Sébastien qui est
copropriétaire avec moi il m'a conjointe
Rachel puis Frédéric mon nom de garçon
aussi qui est employé sur la ferme et sa
conjoint de mode
j'ai rencontré mon conjoint j'étais aux
études en réadaptation physique puis je
suis venu visiter sa bergerie puis je
tombais en amour avec l'agriculteur et
la bergerie comme on dit une entreprise
moderne tournée vers l'avenir mais c'est
la seule ferme du village la dernière
car moi j'ai pris la relève on a pris
commencé à prendre l'expansion on a
grossir puis beaucoup de monde me disait
vous êtes fou de vous lancer là-dedans
faire des investissements majeurs dans
même dans le coin ici village va former
mais si tout le monde se dit ça c'est là
que les villages ont formés dans le fond
[Musique]
car dans les années 60 et 70 le village
Abel est bien failli disparaître bien
petit dernier dans la Vieille Capitale
les
autorites se recevaient le rapport final
du bureau d'aménagement de l'Est du
Québec et numéros diverses
recommandations pour relever le niveau
de vie
une opération sans précédent s'enclenche
le déplacement d'une centaine de
villages vers les villes de l'est du
Québec
l'ascension de pâte à pizza figure sur
la liste des villages à rayer de la
carte
mais la résistance des citoyens avec les
opérations dignité s'élève comme un mur
des idées nouvelles surgissent comme
l'exploitation organisée de leur forêt
et le développement de l'élevage ovins
à l'époque tout le monde disait et fou
le village va former fait pas ça puis
finalement s'il y avait pour faire ça on
se repose qu'on est aujourd'hui
[Musique]
finalement la majorité des villages ont
survécu y compris l'ascension de pâte à
pizza
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui clipse la ferme des coutures met en
marche 2200 agneaux par année marc est
un fier ambassadeur de l'agneau d'ici
du Québec est beaucoup plus gros
beaucoup plus viandes puis à la cuisson
aussi vous allez vous en rendre compte
assez vite un agneau on parle d'agneau
du Québec
je vais être capable de nourrir
peut-être à 10 personnes de ça dure
facilement tandis qu'un judo pour la
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est peut-être de 4 de
4 à 5 personnes puis ils vont en rester
parce que vous allez être déçu
mais quand on est seul les fermes
voisines ne sont pas proches
être la seule ferme ici c'est un côté
insécurité quand tu étais un brie
mécanique être pas être capable de
déstocker de s'entraider en outre la
distance parcourir pour faire abattre
ses animaux et considérables le coût du
transport lui revient très cher d'ici
souvent les agneaux pour passer droite
vont aller se faire abattre dans le coin
de Montréal qu'on parle de ces 10 heures
de transport et plus
pour nous autres
le transport des grès aussi lui coûte
cher c'est pourquoi les coutures
récoltent beaucoup de céréales une
partie sur des terres louées autours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors de la journée portes ouvertes en
2014 les voisins et les ont d'ailleurs
remerciés de sauver leur terre
dans le champs
[Musique]
une portion de plus en plus grande de
leur chance céréales donne des grains à
valeur ajoutée
on a une partie cette année on avait de
l'orge dans le fond qui est pour la
coiffe fédéré pour la semaine on ne
sarrasin aussi qui s'en va en
consommation humaine pour faire une sans
gluten puis on a dû on a de la voix
aussi pourquoi
Saint-Laurent et la Gaspésie ont
longtemps été les leaders en production
en ville avec 70% des fermes du Québec
même que la région s'est mobilisée pour
développer il y a une quinzaine d'années
un agneau spécial nourri d'une moulée
d'algues déshydratée
[Musique]
qui est un petit un petit granule pour
vraiment l'alimentation des animaux
qu'on va donner à l'alimentation
les éleveurs ont voulu produire un
agneau qui se démarque
sur de notre produit
l'éleveur consultante Johann Cameron
alors à l'emploi du centre d'expertise
en production ovine du Québec en 2005 à
mesurer les performances autres
techniques et la santé des animaux
nourrit à une moulée additionnée
d'algues
le rapport à fixé le pourcentage idéal
d'algues dans la ration
au niveau de la composition
des algues ce qui est intéressant c'est
très riche en calcium en magnésium en
potassium mais c'était aussi riche en
sodium puis en iode c'est surtout ces
deux paramètres là qui devaient être
évalué au niveau de la consommation
parce que des seuils qu'on doit
respecter au niveau alimentaire chez les
animaux
[Musique]
au début du projet les éleveurs
souhaitaient récupérer la nourriture sur
les berges des environs
mais avec les conclusions de l'étude ils
ont vite de chanter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa valeur ajoutée c'est de garder des
familles agricoles des régions c'est
adhérer à ce produit là c'est c'est
comme encourager les familles agricoles
dans des régions où il y avait de
l'Exode agricole fait que c'est ça la
valeur ajoutée
[Musique]
j'aime ça
parce que moi mon plus gros travail ici
c'est de sauver les agneaux
à l'ascension de pâte à pizza la
dernière ferme en opération est bien
vivante moi j'ai un garçon 3 ans mon
frère une petite fille d'un homme
peut-être que ça sera le futur j'allais
peut-être qu'on aura une relève
étrangère aussi on se pose en espérant
que ça continue puis bien quelqu'un sur
notre passion comme nous autres on a
suivi la passion de mon père
[Musique]